you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is around
one game from the 2016 Bilbao masters
final between Magnus Carlsen playing on
the white end and Hikaru Nakamura so
let's dive right in and see what would
happen in their 31st classical encounter
efore by Carlson Sicilian on board a
flexible move to nighty to allowing for
some different white setups depending on
Black's next couple moves in the game d6
Knights III and a flexible non-commital
a6
waiting move waiting for what
waiting to see whites 4th will it be d4
or something else in the game or
something else g3 and only after g3 g6
notice the importance of making a
flexible waiting Universal type move on
this move three with a six if there's
the more committal move g6 white can go
straight in for d4 and what do we have a
Sicilian dragon a far less common
opening at least at the very top level
far less common then let's say a
Sicilian Knight Orff a Sicilian I Dorf
can spring about after a six
if d4 is played now that is exactly the
road we go down instead after a six its
g3 g6 both sides fiend keto white gets
in d4 while he can
hustling would allow knight c6 and how
are you getting in d4 so d4 right now
cd19 both sides complete Kings side
development and now b3 white looks to
exchange off what I consider to be
blacks most valuable minor piece for as
long as the Queen's are present at least
and that is the dark square bishop both
of these bishops the fiend cut out
bishops are in my eyes the most valuable
minor pieces without them the King is
much more vulnerable knight c6 Knights
are exchanged but should be too
to be expected Queen a5 looks for a
light square bishop exchanged a queen
transfer to h5 coupled with Bishop h3
white opens the bishops eyes Bishop g4
Queen e1 offering a queen exchange black
declines computer views this is best
with the Knight d7 and this endgame if
there is some pull its maybe for white
where is there an advantage if any or
where's there potentially an advantage I
believe that is something related to
pawn structure light may try to create
some type of pawn exchange and create an
accessible target maybe one day if these
guys are exchanged maybe this is
something that can you know something
that white can bite out it's not an
advantage one way or the other related
to pieces something related to structure
creating or trying to at least create
some kind of target within one another
structure and I believe it is white who
could who could really be the side if
there is one side that could maybe
inflict some target within the other
structure it's white doing so to black
we don't have the Queen exchange instead
Queen h5 and now f3 this is a very
committal move a bit of a surprising
move it weakens the King along the
diagonal and rank this is really the
best Hut for the King and F to G 3 H 3
or even H 2 structure but as soon as you
touch the F pawn as soon as he's moved
one or two squares King is far more
vulnerable especially with the Queen
still on board but why has his idea and
it's one related to sidelining the black
queen there is a much less committal
move on this move fourteen one that
keeps the pawn still on f2 and instead
be five this is another direction black
works to me white can go in looking to
exchange off a couple puns welcome a
queen exchange and enter an ending where
there are a couple targets
for white to bite out
it's not a direction my cozen goes for a
much more committal plan with first f3
the Queen is restricted so one of the
ideas just in general once you identify
one of your opponent one of your
opponent's pieces is being restricted or
having a defensive role you look to kick
it around try to deflect it from its
task in this case the Queen has to watch
over the Bishop g4 Queen h6 is an only
move Queen is guarding H form and now we
have rook a to d1 this may be tempting
right but there is Queen takes pawn and
the bishop is pinned so you can't
continue to attack the queen with g5 but
what may be tempting at this point is
Bishop to c1 this was not played in the
game again rook a to d1 was played but
let's just consider Bishop c1 g5 is a
necessity and what would you do here
it's an important moment maybe an
interesting
pop quiz what might you do in this
position seeing that the Queen now is
overloaded to watch over both Bishop and
pawn so would you take here and after
Queen takes Bishop take here next and be
up upon or would you take here and after
Queen takes on h3 take the g5 pawn if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what move you would do or maybe your
choice would be none of the above let me
just point out now what the worst move
would be in my opinion at least and it
would be to give up the dark square
Bishop you're up upon it's true as white
but opposite color bishops and that
isn't so much of a factor to be down
upon it's more related to who can better
put to use their Bishop and as it stands
right now White has some serious dark
square weaknesses on the Kings side and
on top of that it's one that could be
exploited right away with tonight h5
taking advantage the pin and he
we'll soon be a beast that wouldn't be a
good choice and going in for this well
it's now super messy night takes G for
striking at the rook the King is really
being robbed of his pawn defense Bishop
takes rook Queen takes takes King f2
he's running for his life
there is no Queen takes bishop because
the pin but after f6 Bishop e3 we have a
very unbalanced scary position for white
where he has two minor pieces but a king
that is without any shelter whereas
black he has a rook and two pawns in
exchange for that okay the short story
here is that Bishop c1 white doesn't go
straight in for that but after rook d1
now this is back on
a variation I showed with Bishop takes
rook is no longer there
rip d1 gets out of the bishops way and
this is now something that's on the
cards black plays first g5 Bishop c1 so
this is now threat to take and intake so
black frees up the Queen we can say she
doesn't have to watch over the bishop
anymore King takes bishop
in out queen g6 getting out of this pin
h4 and G takes h4 I must admit you know
when I'm skimming through a game i
skimming through a game initially uh one
of my first reactions as black when I
saw h4 was okay well let's maintain this
pawn on g5 to keep a grip over the f4
square let's play h6 in other words take
stakes it's important to not be of that
hmm to not be in that frame of mind in
this position there is a much bigger
factor going on in this position and it
involves the king positions let's let's
not forget yeah we're trying to
checkmate one another's King let's let's
consider King safety here okay what we
have now if this came about with h6
takes and then the recapture we have a
completely open H file in who's going to
be quicker to make use of that who's
King is maybe a bit more vulnerable
actually the king is already on g2 and
there can be a very quick transfer along
the H file like Canon may be put to use
in other words the H file and get at the
black King maybe even having the rip
pivot on h5 one day so this is one of
the reasons I believe one of the main
reasons why black is just capturing on
h4 you know he one thing here is that
you don't have to worry about a bishop
takes pawn move you are getting rid of
with this capture you are getting rid of
the heart of the King side of blacks
King side pawn structure but how good
how valuable or how defensive upon is a
pawn on g5 it's different if he's on g6
but upon on g5 I don't know what kind of
great defense he's really putting up for
the black king
so we have that capture and white
recapturing and another way to view it
is that without a black pawn on g5 there
is this pawn on g4 who is now pinned
these may be a little bit more
vulnerable without a black pawn on g5
the white king a little bit more
vulnerable with that without a black
pawn on g5 d5 at this point
I believe it is the white king who is
more vulnerable this is why black is
seeking some pawn exchanges looking for
some open files some open diagonals d5
and now g5 not quite sure about the d5
move it's not considered the the best
try here for white it's not threatening
the knight but the idea that white has
in mind is to meet D take C the game
move with f4 this is what was played
where white is giving up a pawn in
trying to keep the position somewhat
closed a better try the computer says is
something like e 5 and then f4 this
allows Queen takes pawn but this is
actually holding as an even evaluation
queenie for king g1 it may be maybe
there's something to do over here on the
h file ok having a an e5 and F for
structure and you know this structure
here kills the bishop and this knight
offsets the knight on d6 it's really
only the Queen for the moment at least
who is a bit of an annoying piece to
light but that's just one piece life
still has to find a way to get another
piece involved into an attack against
the white King short story instead of g5
the computer is recommending a 5 with NF
4 in the game it was g5 d take C f4 so
with this white is now down upon but
does not really have compensation for it
looks for f5 next but that's stopped
cold with e6 c4 we get black
on an open file and goes with the F rook
one of the ideas is to next play 98 look
for a night reposition at any moment the
White King can move and then this will
be a threat so black takes this into
account knowing that the knight on f6 is
or the f6 square I should say is not a a
stable square so going with this rook is
best if you go with the other rook and
the knight wants to go here well there's
now a disconnect between the Brooks rook
f2e 898 right away just looking to
reposition f5 is a fantastic square it
is also for the moment defending e4
Queen f2 and now f5 this is freeing up
the night so he no longer has to defend
e4 black now has a pawn there to defend
a pond and quite an asset is the e4 pawn
he is connected and past Bishop b2
Knight f7 black now looks to undermine
the structure Knight f7 is facilitating
an e5 pawn break dark square Bishop
Sargon it is the White King who is still
more vulnerable than the black king
queen g3 an idea for black at this point
can be to take advantage of the pinch
pun on g5 with h6 so Queen g3 unpin
black simply looks to double on the only
open file one pair of rooks are
exchanged Queen c3 King g8 rook f2 if
the Queen's weren't on the board if King
safety wasn't an issue the knight on c5
would be a very good piece we can see
this pawn picked up and y can look to
just push the a pawn but as it stands
right now the white King you know
his house is on fire there are these
pieces that are swarming in and there is
no time you know to just go pawn
grabbing this knight on c5 almost always
stands well but in a way it's kind of an
out of play
piece pretty rare but I believe that
that is the case here
Queen h5 let me be a bit more specific
pretty rare for a knight to be in this
hole on c5 and for him to be out of play
but in this case I believe he is queen
h5 trying to get the Queen's off is
white black declines white has the more
vulnerable King Queen e3e v is not only
striking here but looking for rook g6
some lateral movement Queen g3 rook g6
takes takes we have check we repeat this
position a little bit there is a time
control it move 40 which is now met so
players gain some time at this at this
point and now black comes up with the
idea to take on g5 tuck the King away on
h6 temporarily it may be tempting at
this point to do something like this but
there's a main two threat Knight h3 and
rook g1 if the King went in the corner
same story
while tempting this pin it's no good
because of night h3 queen f4 pins the
night and now we have a little to move
reposition of the black queen by way of
d1 and then D form fewer pieces on board
the more valuable the queen is on these
center squares d4 hmm what isn't she
doing from d4 striking at the knight
striking at the rook restricting the
Queen as a result and she even has some
defensive task of shielding the King
against diagonal checks as we will soon
see the King is going to take a take up
a post on H a and the Queen will be
there to guard the dark squares
B for defends the night King g7 now the
rook is ready to get involved along the
H file which tried as Queen c7 King h8
Queen c8 the rook blocks Queen takes
pawn
now the knight is hitting there with
check just an enormous piece to a knight
comparison again he's out of play and he
is well within play this is already
leading to checkmate King h3 Queen d6 it
goes no further after Queen d6 white
resigns to mate threats
Queen g3 and Queen h6 no good way to
parry these threats Carlson resigns for
the first time in their 31 encounters
total now 12 losses 18 draws and now one
win he got the monkey off of his back
for the first time so we'll see how
maybe things change in future encounters
feel free to leave any feedback let me
know what you think how maybe this will
again influence future encounters we
have an interest interesting decision
made earlier in this game with that f3
g4 idea feel free to share any thoughts
you have on this game I look forward to
reading the comments as usual and I hope
you got something out of it that's all
for now
take care bye
you